now could mali become the new
afghanistan that's the question burning
in paris and berlin and other european
capitals after france decided to pull
its military out of the crisis torn
country in the sahel now long-running
international missions to stabilize mali
and strengthen its institutions are now
in big trouble and mali is in the group
of a military junta russia has even been
getting involved now germany's foreign
minister annalina bairbach paid a visit
this week to work out what berlin's next
move should be
dw's chief international correspondent
richard walker flew with her to mali
from where he sent us this next report
touching down in a military plane on the
edge of the sahara in mali
this is a dangerous place and german
soldiers scanned the airfield before
opening up to the desert sun
angelina barbock has come here as
germany faces decision time here in mali
should it keep a military presence in a
region shaken by crises of climate
change hunger and terrorism
or after many years and little progress
is it now finally time to quit
france has decided to pull out its
forces a huge step for the former
colonial power
and the eu has ended a mission training
mali's army
this man is the reason why colonel asimi
goyta leads the military hunter that
controls mali after two coups in as many
years
the regime is accused of showing no
interest in returning to democracy
and its deepening ties with russia
that's a big worry for the west
as the war in ukraine rages on
so the outlook was tough as bearbox
toured camp castor the main base for
german operations here
aircraft fly from here on reconnaissance
missions as part of united nations
mission called minusma it aims to bring
some stability to mali
meeting the troops bearbach made it
clear that she wants to stick to the un
mission
and that germany might even have to
commit more as others pull out
against the backdrop that the french
have already announced that they will
withdraw here there is now also a
special responsibility for our country
for the many other countries that are
involved in this mission to consider
together how we can continue this
important stabilization mission in the
the future is can germany deal with the
military hunter
at talks with hunter leaders in the
capital bamako berbach and hermalian
counterpart read loggerheads over mali's
military ties to russia
especially after reports of a massacre
involving russian fighters
this was my urgent appeal
why it's so important including for the
protection of civilians in mali that
there is no cooperation with russian
actors here on the ground
the situation in mali is the situation
in mali and we hope that each of mali's
partners will also respect mali's
choices
mali makes its choices according to its
concerns just as germany makes its
choices according to its concerns
so what happens now well as annalina
balbarg and the delegation of lawmakers
traveling with her return to germany you
can expect an intense debate to flare up
in the weeks ahead but they don't have
that long to decide
next month the bundestag the parliament
will have to vote on whether the mission
will continue
the instability in mali hasn't only
destroyed lives islamist insurgents in
timbuktu also destroyed written history
for decades africa has been seen as a
continent rich in oral traditions but
with few ancient texts but we're now
turning over a new leaf in that old
story by meeting one man in mali who has
devoted himself to preserving ancient
writings from african scholars who
studied at the university of timbuktu
some of these manuscripts date back to
the 11th century making them a thousand
years old but now you can access them
from the phone in your pocket dw news
africa's florist jaguar sent us this
report
relics of history handed down from one
generation to another
the timbuktu manuscripts are a
collection of documents written by
african scholars in mali from the 11th
to the 20th
century more than 400 000 of them are
temporarily stored in this library
the writings cover a broad range of
subjects including arts medicine science
astrology mathematics and politics
everybody says that in africa there is
no written heritage
there is no written history that it's
all oral
but the manuscripts are our identity
they are our history
they are our heritage
really the manuscripts are everything to
us
for decades dr haidera has worked to
preserve and draw attention to these
manuscripts
in 2012 jihadists attacked northern mali
and attempted to destroy historical
buildings and burn the manuscripts
but with the help of locals hydara
secretly transported the manuscripts a
bit at a time by boat and truck to the
capital bamaku
now together with his team and partners
like google hydera has been working to
digitize the manuscripts
they've taken thousands of
high-definition pictures of the
manuscripts and translated the text into
different languages for people all over
the world to use
gang honor
having a digital copy of the manuscripts
will make work easier for researchers
for students
for teachers
and for historians
they'll be able to easily access the
manuscripts on their screens
this particular manuscript that i just
read is titled good governance and the
dangers of power and basically talks
about how giving gifts and money in
exchange for justice is corruption and i
find it's very very fascinating that
from the 11th century we can find so
much wisdom that people and governments
of our day can learn from
digitizing the manuscripts also means
that even if any of them gets lost or
stolen the content will be preserved
online
this digitization process is part of
google's mali magic project
the technology giant is partnering with
historians like hydara to preserve and
share treasures of african heritage with
the world
you